what comes your mind what uh when you
see something like this
that is what they're trying to do but it
actually goes a level deeper
deeper believe in karmic retribution
parents might be stunned to learn that
Bruno's version of love and acceptance
means handing out sex toys to underage
students Balenciaga is one of the
world's most expensive clothing brands
in the world
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around but
this is why they show you and tell you
what they're doing peace be upon him
this is our religion Islam Islam this is
the teacher
when I was ready to talk about this I
would only talk to you I was explaining
how much respect I have for the faith of
Islam
welcome to the beach
foreign
brothers and sisters how you doing thank
you for tuning in to this week's episode
of the D show and we have two esteemed
guests with us starting from my right to
my left Dr sabil Ahmed and Dr Kramer
Jose how are you doing
I want to get in straight into uh this
news that hit it didn't hit mainstream
news from local news not even local news
you just have some independent
journalists who went and had a hidden
camera and this is one of the Deans of a
children's school being recorded in this
video
so let's go ahead and play this and
we'll get your guys reaction to it
lgbtq plus Health Center come in they
were passing around butt plugs and
dildos to my students talking about
queer sags using blue versus using spit
meet Joe Bruno dean of students at the
prestigious Francis W Parker private
school in Chicago which happens to
charge forty thousand dollars per
student they're just like passing around
dildos butt plugs the kids are just
playing with them they're like how do
you how does this book work how do we do
like how does this work that's a really
like a little part of my job parents
might be stunned to learn that Bruno's
version of love and acceptance means
handing out sex toys to underage
students in the Deep for four years
during Pride we do a pride week every
year and I had
um
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using lube versus using
bed who was this this is uh the lgbtq
plus Health Center came in to talk to my
high school today they're just like
passing our dildos butt plugs the kids
are just playing with them they're
looking at uh in the school in a
classroom wow yeah well I'm sitting
there and we had a drag queen come in uh
pass out cookies and brownies and do
photos
and everybody's cool with that like
they're about plugs and their dildos
nobody complaints I mean if the parents
found out that they you know
queer sex this is the drag queen that
came in what's her name uh Alexis bevels
Alexis bevels and just hung out in my
classroom and was there hung out in my
office you have so much freedom and so
much
wiggle room
so much money I mean YouTube stuff these
are okay with that too
I don't know okay dean of students you
send your child to go to school to learn
how to read write math science sociology
you know all the different uh subjects
that they teach
and then they bring in the health
someone from the health department who's
throwing around sex toys
what do you uh
what was your reaction when you uh
what comes your mind what uh when you
see something like this
is
do not wish for death
you know do not wish to die
but say o Allah make life
or make me live as long as life is good
for me
and
send me to death
cause me to die
if death
is good for me and life is no longer
good for you
and subhanallah you know sitting in
I wouldn't even imagine
in in my life that this would be a
subject of discussion you know stuff
like that is
top of the line of
Decay moral decay
and you know this person that you showed
us
is a non-muslim this you know Welsh guy
oh the Matt Walsh the Matt Walsh guy
yeah he's a non-muslim and
you know I had a conversation with Dr
Seville right before the shooting this
this show
and and he confirmed that he heard that
statement from him saying that
that I will not stop even if they kill
me I will not stop pushing back
Matt Walsh mentioned that yes and and
where are we Muslims where are we how
come
these public figures in the Muslim world
are not speaking against this how come
they are not
how come
we're not engaged into this activism
you think it's not going to come to you
is going to come right to your door
see the prophet you know debected this
in a beautiful way when he said imagine
a group of people got on a ship some of
them got the upper level and the other
got the lower level what the people in
the lower level wanted to do they they
thought they were doing something good
by the way they had good intention or
let's accommodate everybody
but this is a hole in the ship that will
bring us all down so do you feel that
more of the community leaders the imams
the
the
Scholars who are out there they need to
be more of a voice 100
we should be taking the lead not this
Welsh Muslims should be taking the lead
is this something that Christians Jews
people of other faiths who also they
want to send their kids to learn math
reading science they don't want them
passing around these sex toys
this is crazy this is we're being taught
how to have
sex with the opposite gender
or at all I mean what people are doing
in their private bedrooms
they don't want this out there their
children being exposed to this I don't
think that's something unreasonable and
rational I mean
yeah Bismillah alhamdulillah
this is not the first time I saw that
video every time when I see the same
video I'm not sure why I'm seeing that
many times
speechless shocking and fearful so many
emotions comes to my mind
but what also comes to my mind right
away is that we are the ones Muslims are
the ones Allah has given that assignment
the role to be the moral leaders for
Humanity
so one time just last week we had a
small conference in one of the massagees
and my brother asked me the question you
know brother sabir why all of these
things are happening right in front of
our eyes
I mentioned to that brother
there is a stage and then there are
audience all around the stage we are
supposed to be on the stage educating
Humanity
morally legally spiritually Any Which
Way right educating Humanity we went
away from the stage some other people
are now on the stage and they are the
ones who have become the spokespeople
for Morality
for that reason we'll see these things
right in front of our eyes
that's powerful I was thinking I could
just imagine imagine you're at a
friend's house
and you're at a high rise
and I really want this picture to sink
in and now one of the persons up there
he might have listened to some song you
know they got some song out there from
back in the day uh I Believe I Can Fly
so now he feels like he's of ego a bird
he's about to jump right I mean any
person if he loves this person he would
say hey stop it's obvious you're not an
eagle you can't fly and you want the
best for someone you love your friend
your family member would you let him
jump
that's exactly why are they doing this
now to the children
you know this is people can understand
this analogy right but over here they're
chopping out body parts
you know and people are and they're
pushing this stuff on the children at
such a young tender age
you know if a patient goes to a doctor
saying that you know I don't think I
should have my left arm
please take it off
they would never do it they they may
even call you know the police and the
legal system saying that this guy is
crazy how come he wants his you know arm
chopped off the next day if a girl goes
in
saying that I want to do the top surgery
I don't feel like a woman I want to be a
man
they will say how can we help you we are
all here the team is all here to support
you
look at the disparity
just to answer your question regarding
the children
it is
a satanic scheme
plot
and I'll give you an Evidence you know I
I like all those to provide an Evidence
Muslim
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us that every day
Satan places his throne on water
in the morning at sunrise
and as the his armies from the Jinn from
his race his Regina
come to
start their work
he will give them an incentive by saying
whoever does the best job today in
Mischief in
causing damage I will prize you today
I'll place a crown on your head tonight
this is the main devil this is that I
please the one who refused to the
Christians my nose Lucifer luciferia the
one who refused you can use the same as
Lucifer yeah they say Lucifer iblies
that's the main devil yes
the one who who is living Allah given
him the respite
that he is to live until
the day of judgment so he is and he's
now talking to the little devil the what
would you hear them the Little Devils
yes his Prodigy the one who died yeah
you see we need to we believe there is
Hadith
Jinn and human they die but Iblis
doesn't die
because he requested that respite until
uh Judgment Day so Allah granted him
that
so in any rate so this Gene is he would
give them that incentive
so they would they would go about their
business throughout the day
at sunset
he places his throne on water again
in order to encourage those who are
about to initiate the work at night and
reward those he is very punctual and he
doesn't by the way he doesn't take a day
off he doesn't he shows up to work no
because he he never
24 7 they work again he's working hard
yeah so uh El Hassan al-basri even while
somebody asked him
[Laughter]
will come reporting their
accomplishments throughout the day this
is Hadith by the way this is I'm just
explaining it in my own words so one of
them will say today I was able to get a
Muslim to commit adultery although it's
a major sin we're not belittling that he
would say good job that's a great thing
I was able to get a Muslim to kill
another Muslim oh I love that
I got him to intoxicate to you know he
went to some country uh where they told
him marijuana is legal so legal he said
legal means Halal you know
still Haram but he you know he
Associated this with that and he's
I convinced him I made him they said
it's legal that means it's Halal you
know
you know I got him to think of alcohol
to be spiritual drinks you know I got
this lady to give up her hijab because
of fashion because
he's impressed by all of those until
this one stands up and says I did not
leave a husband and wife until I
separated them they got divorced
broke the family now
and he will say you are my man come out
in in a world of this Hadith by the way
he will hug him
and he will place the crown on him so
you're connecting this Hadith now to the
bigger scheme of things children the
children family who suffers in a divorce
children children who pays the price in
a divorce
he will have weaker generations to sway
too so same thing happening here exactly
affecting yes affecting their children
and and going after the children
I'll give you another example just to to
drive my point across to you
why in the world did the Pharaoh decide
to slaughter
truly
to slaughter the newborn pharaoh the
field
why
because they were a threat
to his scheme to his plan
you understand you know if you read the
Hadith
is called
a statement
that the Pharaoh initially saw a dream
that the fire came from the East burned
all the houses of the Egyptians and they
did not burn any of the houses of the
Muslims at the time because many Israel
were the Muslims at the time
so he asked his counsel what is that he
said well these guys are talking about
the birth of a of a child who will
destroy you who will so basically the
the the established system now whatever
it is they want to maintain
the future and the only way you can do
this is by working on the Next
Generation they already got us
they are winning so far you see they got
us they managed to get
their plan
and action
people are are intimidated to speak
about them we tell me how many Muslims
speakers
how many do art
they consider the subject a threat to
them
threat to the community
and and because they are intimidated
he's afraid he's afraid that the you
know the uh he he may get in trouble
with the with the law he may not be
invited to this conference next what
about because you by professor and a
medical doctor
and night full time of educating people
on Islam and what about you have many
family members who are doctors and many
so many what's the percentage of Muslims
who are doctors and how did how them
speaking from us not just from a
religious standpoint from but also from
a medical standpoint of you know the
harms of this
yeah so I totally aligned with our dear
Sheikh here we should have more speakers
more activists knowing this topic and
speaking about this topic to educate the
people from the Quran from the Sunnah
from a biology psychology physiology
right so there are so many qualified
doctors you know according to one data
10 percent of physicians in the USA
they're Muslims yeah in some cities you
know Dearborn in New York maybe higher
percentage
so these Physicians mashallah they need
to step up and they need to speak out
and they need to provide references
obviously from the Quran Sunnah from
from you know from journals and whatnot
so we need to do it because as I
mentioned if we don't do it then who
will everybody else is throwing in the
towel
so we are the ones Allah has assigned
this humongous moral responsibility
spiritual responsibility uh to direct
the people about who is the creator what
is the purpose of life what are the
solutions how to go to paradise this
bigger connections we need to make with
the society
you know as I mentioned before as I
always mentioned these are all the fires
which are out there in the society yes
we can have teams to fight each one of
the fires
however a better strategy would be to
make sure that we connect Humanity with
the Creator
and show them there is a Creator this is
the purpose of life you know there would
be accountability you have to stand in
front of the creator
so that was the prophetic way
so I'm not saying that we should not go
after all of these Fitness in the
society we should but then there should
be a long-term plan of connecting the
creation with the Creator the bigger
realities of life
there's an individual that many people
gravitate to
and he talks about some of these issues
and now instead of like you're saying
many of the community leaders talking
about them and being a better example to
the youth and others you have other
people who kind of fill that void and
that Gap and you might have heard of
this famous he was one of the most
famous individuals in the world Andrew
Tate
and he talks about also how he came to
reli believe in God because two opposite
forces he saw all this evil what they're
trying to do to the children chopping
out body parts and you know convincing a
a woman that now this other person comes
into the bathroom no that's actually not
a man in the bathroom that's a woman
he's like right in front of your eyes
you know so this convinced him there's
got to be a higher power of God then he
went towards Christianity and then he
came finally to Islam and may Allah God
Almighty increased him really in the
proper knowledge so he can be a better
example because many people gravitate to
many of these things that he's bold
enough to talk about where many Muslims
themselves are lacking to talk about
these things I think a lot of Muslims
Brothers just to give them the benefit
of the doubt you know the imams and the
speakers they are afraid of the
consequences
um alhamdulillah probably are aware of
both of you are aware of aim authentic
and Mission we actually invited
a lawyer a brother his name is eunos
he used to be a
Jew actually who accepted Islam and he
is advocate for Islam now so we put
together something called Sharia defense
and we invited him to the last aim
conference in Colorado in Denver
and he actually presented he said and
and this message goes to every uh Imam
out there as long as you reference
the Quran and Sunnah no one can come
near you
and subhanallah and we're talking about
this last night when Allah revealed over
80 verses
in the Quran about yeah about what their
agenda is
brothers and sisters in Islam I want to
tell you something you see I'm going to
believe my Lord my creator
those guys agenda are to turn you
them
look what they said to loot and his
family
Loot and his family what did they say
get them out of here expel them
from this town
because they want to stape you
they recognize that they are impure
they want to stay straight so their
agenda is not only your child you
they're going to come after you that's
their agenda
uh you can imagine even the guests
of of a flute the two angels of course
for them they were human because they
talk on human forms so that's their
agenda and again I'm not saying this in
the context of inciting hate or anything
and no no I'm just letting you know that
this is how those guys are going about
it
yeah so like you said that's a good
point nobody's inciting violence hate
bullying none of those things but at the
same time you can't have our children
being exposed to things that are going
to harm them and that we don't agree
with his parents like for instance you
had just recently balenciago is a famous
very famous brand I just heard about it
recently and then they had in their ad
they had a child dressed in bondage
in bondage and then they had a document
all these subliminals you would think
this is some kind of conspiracy but
right it's it's like they're showing you
right in front of your face I don't know
if you guys heard of this balenciago and
then they had a court document of a
pedophilia case there so they were and
then all these other
um things in the video did you hear
about this I have not yet no so this is
uh so he's trying to convince people of
his so they pulled it yeah you know
people protested they pulled it we'll
show this people will be able to see
this it's easy to write off smart people
doing stupid things doing competence or
haste but this one just it doesn't make
sense first the facts Balenciaga is one
of the world's most expensive clothing
brands in the world and for some reason
their Christmas ad campaign included
pictures of a child with a bear when you
zoom on on the bear it's dressed shall
we see unusually people who know about
these things say its outfit is inspired
by bondage outfits used in certain sex
acts this in and of itself is troubling
then there's another ad you zoom in on
it and you see the papers laying around
the bag that is being advertised is
printouts of a child pornography case
specifically United States versus
Williams in 2008 that upheld the law
making child Point illegal next add to
the celebrities who endorse Balenciaga
it's a who's who from Kim Kardashian to
Haley Bieber but again you have uh
people who get outraged on certain
things that will happen to society but
again the push then you have another
brother now Andrew Tate he steps he's
talking about it it was done on purpose
which as we've just deciphered it must
have been why are they doing this and I
don't think many people understand why a
brand like Balenciaga would so openly
show the world that they are trying to
promote pedophilia tell them I'll tell
them why so some could argue that
they're trying to
advertise it and
encourage it normalize normalize and
that is the case that is what they're
trying to do but it actually goes a
level deeper than that satanists people
who worship Satan believe in karmic
retribution they believe that they can
suffer the consequence of lying and
tricking you so the very simple premise
is this if I sell poison apples and I
write apples and you come and eat one I
poisoned you but if I sell poison apples
and I have a sign that says apples
they're poison and you come and eat one
you commit suicide I haven't murdered
you you've committed suicide that's what
satanists believe Satan is believed by
telling you what they're doing they
don't have any karmic retribution I'm
not responsible for the for the the
concept I'm not responsible for all the
negative Fallout from my actions if they
understood what I was doing and allowed
me to do it this is why they show you
and tell you what they're doing if I
show you and tell you that we are
pedophiles and you continue to buy our
products then you're supporting
pedophilia and you're obviously okay
with us being pedophiles if I do it
hidden behind your back then you could
argue and say I didn't know therapeutic
files but by showing you I've shown you
I'm a pedophile you still want to wear
my t-shirt so obviously what I'm doing
is okay and this karmic retribution
model and the way that satanists view
the world and when I say Satanist I
genuinely mean people say worship real
things the people who are in charge of
these Brands and in charge of the
Western World in charge of the Matrix
genuinely worship Satan when you
understand the idea of karmic
retribution you can apply that to so
many scenarios they're doing this with
everything karmic retribution isn't just
about Balenciaga but then the Muslims
are silent so when these things come out
what do you think the reaction should be
from Muslims just the same way we are
appalled there sometimes will get in on
a bandwagon it's kind of you know the
social justice of course we should be
against any kind of Injustice but these
things were just like quiet
some of the recommendations that I can
provide would be we should form we
should form coalitions of the imams
along with Interfaith Partners to
amplify our voice and to have that much
more uh you know force with us
secondly there should be Alliance
alliances of psychologist alliances of
the medical doctors right alliances of
sociologists all of this alliances
should be there because there are so
many people out there who are thinking
the same way we are thinking but they
may not know how to start where to start
so that's number one number two would be
the imams council there are so many out
there right uh amja and others and then
they should be the massages and the
councils that they are there in many
different states and cities like the
ciogc in Chicago and different councils
they should get together they should
have a session about what is the proper
strategy to tackle this fitna
and number third thing would be there
should be a qualified lawyer says Imam
has mentioned
not just a Sharia defense but also
especially against these issues when
they come up in the massages like
suppose if tonight if a man comes in
dressed as a female and that guy wants
to pray next to our ladies
does does your Masjid has a defense for
it
are you legally covered if you stop that
person are you legally covered because
he or she may say well here right not
she he may say that this is my right
this is my human right this is my right
to be equal
so we should have qualified lawyers
standing with us every major should have
policy in the lawyers so these are some
of the minimal things that we can do
along with that you know we should not
be afraid of LGBT but we should be doing
dawa to them
because at the end of the day I mean I
feel sorry for them they're not educated
shaytan is after them and all of that
so not only we should distance ourselves
to some degree so the fitna does not
come to us but ultimately our aim should
be that there should be recipients of
education and dawa and who is the
creator
so any and all of these strategies which
should come and and you know make like a
really specific structured plans that's
how we can have a good pushback
using our scriptures using the Quran
using the Sunnah ultimately using the
team of qualified people inshallah by
the way I asked we asked in the
conference am conference the Sharia
defense head lawyer about this issue of
the masjids he said as long as for now
he said for now but these guys are very
Progressive they yes yes they they are
changing the laws day after day and you
probably know why because they gotten
onto the agenda of black lives matter
you know matter you know that that the
Civil Rights Movement basically they
Associated themselves with they work
together basically so all the Privileges
uh you know the the Civil Rights
Movement from the 60s get the these guys
they get as well in some states of
course so he said that as long as the
Masjid announces their policy
they cannot violate that just put your
policy on your website or on the walls
no one can come and and violates that
for now for now because they have turned
this into a civil rights and human
rights and equal rights issue just like
the racism was right if that happens we
cannot happen the Masjid that you know
brown people or white people or you know
black people they cannot come and pray
or they have to be praying in a
different way separate way
the way that we cannot have that for the
race they may come and say you know this
is a human rights issue you cannot have
that policy or those wordings so for now
we can do that but down the line there
have to be other things coming to play
and I give that example of this
University I'm not sure Yale or some
University no not here there was a
Jewish campus
and some kids in there they want to open
a LGBT club and the school said this is
a private property so that those kids
they went to the Supreme Court
and the Supreme Court backed them saying
that they have the right even in a
private property Jewish school they have
the right to open a LGBT Club
so they are coming to that extent so
simple message is this that yes we have
to be concerned but we have to have a
channel our emotions into activism
we have to educate our own families we
have to create a environment in the home
to such a degree that mashallah you say
to your children right be a man
and we need to educate them this is
right and this is wrong and then we need
to make every single Muslim
a moral activist in the society we need
to remind the Muslims Allah has given us
a humongous humongous assignment it's
not just to pray it's not just to build
the massages we are supposed to be the
moral authorities we are supposed to be
letting people know who is the creator
connecting them with the with the higher
power any and all of those things we
have to create them within our children
and our families
and we need to do the war to the Creator
ultimately he's the one in power
so when you know the laws you know you
have freedom of speech and you have a
right to have freedom of religion no one
can force you to wear a cross eat pork
do something against your religion
that'd be an oppression so when you have
doctors out there and they're forced and
I spoke to an attorney he said they
don't have to if they know the law where
a certain color on their body you know
to go ahead and unify and get in so when
you know you're right same to tomorrow
when a Muslim doctor is approached to go
off cut off a body part from someone you
know for them to know are they allowed
to do this [ __ ] no I'm as long as you
see there is a religious freedom here
that goes against that Freedom that they
are claiming to which is really in my
opinion
has nothing to do with freedom I mean
you see your sexual preference is in
your bedroom keep it in the bedroom
that's we have nothing to do with that
why are you pushing this on my kids so
are you saying the same way let's say a
husband he's into he tried he's doing
you know things with his wife same thing
as long as it is local you don't need to
hear about yourself no so it's across
the board no that's across the board
even even when you go and and request a
fatwa it should be in private yeah you
know nobody needs to know about that you
see that's that that's the really the
the the the the Twisted Wicked
uh point is equating this with the Civil
Rights Movement you see these brothers
you know in humanity they are not
Muslims they were the Muslim
African-American Community they were
discriminated against because of their
color it can hide your color can you
you know you can't go to that restaurant
because you're of a certain color
you can hide that but your sexuality is
is your private thing what do I have to
do with it so even see people understand
this because you live in such a loose
culture that the man will come around
his friends and he'll talk about the
relation these are usually not Muslims
how he's have with his wife it's a sin
in Islam to disclose to talk about
Uruguay your wife or your husband how
you guys head intimacy this that is
what's Haram that's Haram that's a sin
and so all this stuff across the board
this is immoral you see we have a
treatment for all of this in the Quran
and Sunnah and that is why I crawl upon
my brothers and sisters in the field of
dawah come on brothers
don't worry about your fans don't worry
about your conferences Allah Allah will
provide
but the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam says if you see something bad
speak out
speak out
and and there is a threat out there that
Dr Sabine mentioned that that you know
if you don't do that your God is not
going to be accepted one of the as a
consequence of of being silent on on
on Grievous issues like these and I'm
shy bringing this up but this is in
essence of just education and helping
people understand where we're coming
from an Islamic perspective because even
if a husband to want to perform that
sexual act from the wrong
um door this is also something that's
Haram that's Haram so
uh intercourt how can I put it more just
softly with even a husband with his wife
that's something that's Haram you can't
even do that we don't you see it's it's
it's again it's the fitra to to do that
you you see Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
brothers and and sisters in Islam Islam
is a lifestyle
Islam teaches us how to go to the
bathroom
in what Manner should you
execute
and in what Manner should you enter and
should you come out imagine that if
Israel I'm a Muslim you know
a politics
a man from Berger met Salman you know
Salman is Virgin
and and he asked him your religion
teaches you everything even how to go to
the bathroom
he said yeah
yeah my religion teaches me out and he
described to him the prophet told us to
not to use the right hand to use the
left hand and use at least three objects
to remove the impurities from the body
and and
make dwara and
yeah be proud of that that this is a
religion that teaches you
your boundaries your limits because if
you cross look at this too
[Music]
there are some boundaries don't come
near them
and there are some boundaries don't
cross them
coming near May invite you to cross so
stay away from it
yeah you understand so
submit to Allah Allah is your maker your
creator
and he told you how to conduct all these
things your sexual life your emotional
life your
blueprint for life everything is there
your purpose in life the main thing your
purpose in life you go and buy a car
what they give you with the car
Emmanuel
why why they are entitled to give you
that manual because they are the
manufacturer the maker we may use the
Creator they are the creator of the car
who created you and me
who
he brought down the manual
that manual instruct us how to conduct
Our Lives
now if we abandon that manual and follow
these satanic
it's endless it's a dark hole it's very
dark hole so let's end with that you
know now there's an invitation and we do
this out of the love Mercy For Humanity
because the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessed be upon Him is the last and
final messenger sent as a mercy to all
mankind doesn't mean it doesn't matter
am I correct Shake tell them you know Dr
Bill that doesn't matter what kind of
Lifestyle a person was on yesterday
today they can come back to their
creator and change their way for the
better huh and be forgiven Dr sebil
mentioned it twice
so you see look at Ayah is
her statement
all what we learned in Makkah was who's
Allah
and Hill
basically who's Allah and if you believe
in him submit to him you're going to get
Jannah and if paradise and if you
decline turn away Hellfire
both in the world and the Hereafter by
the way by the way now people like those
they are so much engulfed into their
desires and whims
shackle some of them are Shackled
because some of these things are
addictions by the way they are not
so the only way for them to come out of
this is connecting them with the Creator
turn back to the Creator yeah imagine
intoxicants intoxicants you know you
know the Hadith regarding Alhambra and
toxic if it comes right away the whole
thing yeah intoxicant why because Allah
said
you know so uh
whoever you are out there if you have
these thoughts
if you have these tendencies
you're a human
we're all sinners
come back to the Creator we're not
acting now like they say we're holier
than no we're better
may Allah may Allah
but seek the Creator if you are in that
you know domain
if you are thinking about it don't
don't it has devastating consequences in
this world and in the hereafter
three quick points especially for the
Muslim youth for listening be proud of
you being a Muslim Islam is the best
faith this is the only Faith Allah has
given to humanity so be proud to be a
Muslim
secondly really important that educate
yourself about this topic there are some
Halal things there are some Haram things
so these are all the Haram things the
people what they are doing just because
there's a pressure from your family and
your friends and your social media
always think
what does Islam say about the topic
always align yourself always have the
frame of reference the Quran and the
authentic Sunnah and last important
thing is not only knowing what is right
and wrong but act upon become activist
become an activist for the social change
and that's when inshallah you will get
the best reward here and inshallah the
highest place in Paradise so we have a
mission we have a you know many good
things that we should be doing in the
society
so join forces with the good-hearted
good-minded people inshallah Allah would
be on our side amen thank you thank you
both Dr sabil and Dr Kareem abuse thank
you very much for helping us to tackle
this topic because inshallah this could
be a benefit so many how many more
people out there
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum